let's go next to our caller from the 508
area code uh 508 what's your name where
are you calling from
hello can you hear me yes i can who's
this
yes um i am adam from moster and i just
want to start off by saying that i've
been a big fan of your show for many for
like 10 years now thank you it's just
for
the past couple of years i have been
quite disappointed with your russia
investigation coverage
really you don't seem to put
you don't seem to put out there to your
viewers
counteracting evidence that discredits a
lot of this
the russia gate narrative that's been
pushed by the democratic party i'm on
the left
yeah i i hate trump i just
i just think it's for the past couple of
years this is like a bit of conspiracy
theory
that's not really based on a lot of
facts
okay so adam can we let's slow down
though because you're saying a lot and
we want to make this a conversation
what specific assertion have i made that
was incorrect
well um well
you your last russia video was about
uh that it's not a hoax that it's
that it's it's not it's because of some
information that came out
about paul manafort and i mean the
the entire investigation was started
fraudulently no so adam let's let's
let's just deal with that
so the the the recent video
was an analysis of a report that was put
out
by the senate select committee uh headed
up by
a republican richard burr which
confirmed
most of the initial suspicions about
interactions between the trump campaign
and russia in the time leading up to the
election
now for you to say okay go ahead
yes yes so with paul manafort it killed
kilimnik right that's one of dozens of
components yes
well wait did you know what paul
manafort was doing in ukraine
he was doing a lot of different things
over a long period of time but i don't
know
if which ones which things you're
talking about and how they're relevant
to what's in the report
well it is relevant because there's a
narrative out there that
that paul manafort and in kilimnik were
like were just were trying to put its
bidding or
the the funny but hold on adam adam hold
on a second
did i say that or what are you
responding to right now because i don't
say that in the clip you just mentioned
to me what i say in the clip
is read the senate select committee
report
and you will see that if your
expectation was
trump and putin are going to get caught
on video colluding
that obviously did not happen and it's
not what the outcome is going to be
but if you look at the regular
connections and interactions
between the trump campaign and russians
they are confirmed by the report now you
can disagree with the report but that's
not
me right i'm just telling you what's in
the report
you don't like but one what i'm what i'm
counteracting is your assertion that
it proves that it's not a hoax of course
it's not
so how would it be a hoax when you've
seen countless arrests
and essentially everything that was
seriously alleged with evidence
proven either in the mueller report or
in the senate select report
if you're trying to cartoonify the the
claim if you're trying to say listen
david
you were expecting trump and putin to
get caught in bed together colluding
and for trump to be removed then i would
say i never said that i don't know who
was saying that but maybe you should
talk to them but
you it sounds like you're saying it was
a hoax when every serious investigation
has turned out that it was not a hoax
now
if you're saying does it matter if
you're saying
does it is it relevant to trump's
re-election or whatever
i'm probably right there with you but to
say it was a hoax
seems completely without evidence well
i'm not
wait i'm not i'm not saying i'm not
saying that the invest
the investigation itself is that it just
made it just
what i'm saying is that
the the with paul manafort and kim
kilimnik it doesn't so what if he had
connections with some russian people
kill him nick
he was the state defense department
intel source
with a there's a hundred pages that
that might that mueller himself had
that described kilimnik as a sensitive
intelligence source
for the u.s state department
right but it was but it was trump's
campaign chairman
who was briefing him on the campaign it
was not those were not in
who so then that would be an argument
for american intelligence to be dealing
with him in some way
and if you want to claim that they
should have been then you know go ahead
and talk about that but that has nothing
to do with paul manafort in the
propriety of that interaction they were
business partners
it wasn't it wasn't of course they were
going to
communicate and uh there's als my main
problem with this
this russia narrative is that it's
it's just not based on reality people
people are using it
to describe trump as a puppet of russia
but adam hold on a second hold on a
second hold on a second
who is doing that because this is not
even an issue i mean
on my program this hasn't even been an
issue for for like a year and a half at
this point
and we're focused on whether we want to
vote for joe biden or donald trump and
the failed handling of coronavirus i
mean you seem so wrapped up in paul
manafort and stories from a year and a
half ago
who's talking about this now who's
making this the issue for the election
like what are you trying do you
are you trying to get me to say i was
wrong about everything find specific
claims i was wrong about then but so far
you're listing things i haven't even
said i'm not
saying i'm not i'm not here to own you
i'm a fan of yours
i get it but you said you're
disappointed in my coverage and so far
you've only listed things adam hold on
you've listed
things that i've not said as why you're
disappointed with me
no i said i've disappointed that you
haven't pushed back
on this a lot of these because you have
pushed back a lot of stuff like ill on
omar
anti-semitism and please
i agree with you on those it's just that
in here you have a blind spot
because there's a lot of facts that just
don't add up to what
on okay so that's what i'm saying tell
me tell me what i've
all right adam i gotcha i appreciate the
phone call
okay all right he hung up all right very
good i mean it's like what so
okay i i just don't know where to go
with that i really don't
um let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we will be
right back on the phones momentarily